c'est un non dit de dos
c'est lui alors guy bedos ne peux vous
dire est venu accompagné à peu son
couleurs je veux dire que celui là c'est
mon copain il faut pas l'abîmer
oui parce qu'il a fait pour moi quelque
chose qui est assez rare erreur du
copinage et qu'est ce qu'il a fait bah
il m'a donné tout son temps tout son
talent toute son intelligence plus
élevée pour mais arrête les accords je
parle aussi de manhattan pour m'aider à
fait à faire ce one man show que
j'aurais jamais fait j'aurais jamais osé
je trouvais complètement outrecuidant
d'aller pérorer pendant une heure et
demie même plus sur une selle et c'est
lui qui m'a dit à imad la première chose
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a rigolé et que
quand monsieur bedos rigole avec
quelqu'un sur une scène
on peut penser sans être outrageusement
prétentieux que peut-être un petit peu
rigolo quelques appâts ghysel c'est la
première fois vous avez un jeune
s'attendant en fait justement
généralement quand on arrive à maturité
dans ce métier on se met à errer jeunes
parce que on a à sa carrière derrière
soi et moi je me suis dit c'était
intéressant d d un vieux il vaut mieux
commencer à être s'élève à 44 ans que de
sombrer dans le bruit à 25
oui non mais tu pourrais citer même des
non non ce que je veux dire plus
sérieusement encore qu'il faut pas il
faut pas être sérieux trop longtemps
parce que je regarde l'émission il ya
des gens qui sont trop sérieux dans
cette émission mais du coup ça fait
chier
c'est vrai on vous l'avez vous l'avez
pas vous l'avez conseillez vous à lui
l'âme et le stylo et moi j'avais le
ciseau c'est à dire que comme je suis
effectivement un client pour lui et que
je ris
à presque tout ce qui fait qu'en juillet
un peu moins il n'assistait pas y couper
et du coup le spectacle était patent il
réussira jamais à lui s'il reste de la
place
bon comment faire pour donner au public
d'aller le voir je suis et je resterai
dit oui j'ai déjà dit j'ai pas mangé oui
non mais j'ai noté du contexte jeu mais
il ya des aphorismes la décence
humoristique qui sont contestables
quelquefois sur le fond des yeux
dans la vie il faut savoir choisir comme
disait himmler en quittant rochlitz pour
aller visiter la hollande
on ne peut pas être à la fois au four et
au moulin
mais à l'intérieur non mais ça donne ça
donne bien alors sur moi c'est ce qui me
plaît chez des proches c'est que chaque
fois qu'il passe à la télé il ya des
appels téléphoniques et là il ya souvent
des anciens nazis qui vont dire qu'il
faut pas se moquer d'un mort d'accord on
continue je hais d'humanité plus je
connais les hommes plus j'aime mon chien
plus je connais les femmes - j'aime ma
chienne
on va y aller tout genre de conférence
qui s'est absolument pas la scène
pendant une heure et demie au moins
j'étais un peu des tweets depuis non
c'est parce que les arrangements
enfin bref et c'est pas c'est pas une
suite de sketches et pas mais ça a rien
à voir avec moi c'est différent c'est
différent c'est drôle aux saillies que
c'est moins bien c'est différent et donc
il peut pas faire un aussi bon qu il
tourne tourne en dérision quand même oui
c'est ça leur plaît c'est qu'il est
complètement irrespectueux je trouve que
c'est bien parce que depuis quelques
temps même les comics ont tendance à se
prendre au sérieux
bon alors pas ça seulement pour moi bien
sûr alors vivre vivent heureux en
attendant la mort bon pierre des corps
[Musique]
c'est non